نتحدث عن خلافات متعدده بين نتنياهو ووزير
الدفاع جالنت بين معسكر الجنرالات واليمين
المتطرف ما عمق كل هذه الخلافات وما
تاثيرها على مسار
الحرب مساء الخير هي تجاوزت مساله توصيفها
على انها خلافات وصلنا الى حد يمكن القول
فيه ان هناك تشظي كنا نقول دائما ان
التشظي بدا يعني يظهر في اوساط الراي
العام الاسرائيلي بحكم ان هناك خلافات
يعني ما بين اقطاب مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
والحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن الان وصلنا الى
الحد الذي يمكن القول فيه فعلا ان هناك
تشدي داخل مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي وداخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا يوجد اتفاق على
ادنى الامور سابقا كانت الخلافات حول
استراتيجيه او رؤيه ال مجلس الحرب لمجلس
الحرب لما يمكن ان تؤول اليه الحرب بمعنى
مستقبل قطاع غزه والبعد الاستراتيجي لهذه
الحرب لكن حتى حتى في ما هو تكتيكي بدا
الان بدات الان الخلافات تظهر بشكل عميق
الان برايي نحن نتحدث عن مسارين داخل مجلس
الحرب المسار الاول وهو الذي يريد ابقاء
العمليه العسكريه على ما هي عليه لاجتثاث
اسباب ما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر وهذا
المسار يقوده بنيامين نتنياهو وهو يضلل
الجمهور بقدرته على احداث هذه الانجازات
بمعنى اجتثاث حركه حماس وكل مقومات حركه
حماس وما الى ذلك من اهداف اعلنت في بدايه
الحرب لكن المسار الثاني وبرايي هو الاقوى
وربما يكون المدعوم امريكيا هو الانتقال
الى مرحله جديده تؤمن بانه لا يمكن اجتثاث
حركه حماس والانتقال الى مسار اعاقه
وتثبيط حركه حماس او اي من فصائل المقاومه
على القيام بمهامها هذا يتفق مع رؤيه جلنت
التي لمح لها من خلال الحديث عن مباحثات
مع مصر ويتفق ايضا مع رؤيه جانس الذي كان
يتحدث سابقا عن يعني امكانيه ايجاد
ترتيبات خاصه في قطاع غزه ومدعومه مما
يعني صرح به بالامس من قبل كيربي بانه
حركه حماس ستبقى موجوده وما زال لديها
مقدرات وبالتالي لا يمكن التعامل معهم على
انهم مجموعه من الارهابيين يمكن تحييدهم
من خلال عمليه عسكريه هذه الامور كلها
ستلقي بضلالها في المرحله القادمه تفض
واضح يعني بغض النظر عن ايه امكانيه تنفيذ
الرؤيا واضح ان هناك هدف معين من وراء
اعلان جالنت عن رؤيته ل غزه ما بعد حرب
وهي رؤيه مختلفه جذريا عما يعبر عنه رئيس
الحكومه ماذا نفهم من ذلك لناحيه الدلالات
والتوقيت كذلك الذي يتزامن مع وصول بلينكن
الى اسرائيل
والمنطقه بدانا يعني ربما ليس في هذه
الساعات يعني هذا الامر خلال الايام
الماضيه تطور لكن بدا اكثر وضوحا في هذه
الساعات هي عمليه التوظيف السياسي للحرب
لم يعد يعني يخفى الان على اي مراقب انه
ما يجري حاليا في اسرائيل عمليه توظيف
للمعلومات وتوظيف سياسي لما يجري في
العمليه العسكريه من اجل غايات سياسيه غير
مرتبطه حقيقه بمجرى العمليات العسكريه
داخل قطاع غزه الان وانما مرتبطه بمستقبل
بعض الشخصيات السياسيه والاحزاب السياسيه
وما يمكن ان تؤ اليه الامور من حيث اعاده
ترتيب النخبه السياسيه لاحقا هذا ربما ما
يفسر ايضا ما تفضلتم بالاشاره اليه قبل
الظهور معكم حول مساله منع يعني
الاجتماعات ما بين رؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه
و جالنت هذه ليست مساله رمزيه شكليه
يريدها بنيمين نتنياهو بقدر ما هي محاوله
احتكار المعلومات ومحاوله الاستثمار قدر
الامكان في هذه المعلومات من اجل ابقاء
بنيامين نتنياهو على سده الحكم لفتره اطول
بالاضافه الى ذلك بدات تتكشف الان بعض
الاوراق انه حتى داخل مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي ليس فقط بنيمين نتنياهو الذي
يريد توظيف ما يجري حاليا من اجل اسعافه
لاحقا في اعاده بعثه سياسيا او احزابهم
سياسيا وانما ايضا بيني جانس وجنت بدر
درجه اقل وهم يعملون الان على قدم وساق من
اجل جر يمين نتنياهو لاظهار اسوا ما لديه
من خلال العديد من التصريحات المتناقضه من
خلال اظهاره على انه لا يحضى حتى بظهير
داخل مجلس الحرب ومن خلال ايضا اظهاره على
انه الشخص غير قادر على حمايه اسرائيل من
خلال التصريح الذي قدمه جلنت بالحديث على
انه بنيامين نتنياهو من خلال هذه السياسات
يقود اسرائ يقود مجلس الحرب او يقود
الحكومه للادرار بالامن القومي الاسرائيلي
شكرا اشكرك بلال الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الخليل ضيفنا من الخليل